le premier feu l'univers celle où bien
donc c'est l'avant-dernier feu de l'été
comme en beaucoup d'endroits voyez je
m'attendais à tout va la piscine alors
je fais partie du conseil de la bce lors
d'un bain rouge porte le noir à
construire de petits noirs bien
longtemps il a utilisé jourdan par
alliance c'est la capitale de matane le
parisis vous êtes accepté de venir avant
que ce soit la mode un peu loin d'aller
à huy ménages et des couvertures sous
l'occupation
parce que cette époque la passe de trop
jeune pour le savoir mais on mangeait
des rues de la bahia et ma femme dit les
lourdeurs il y avait une carte de l'est
j'écrivis de très nombreux dialogues de
films et il y a un trou dans les films
qui sort ces jours-ci il s'appelle quand
passent les faisant exactement comme il
le faisait ces deux c'est un fils
d'edouard molinaro avec paul meurisse
gens ne faisaient bernard blier et est
ce que tous les trois dans ce film sont
parfaitement connaître
ils sont partis comme elle en est sûre
les escrocs des repas seront fallait des
petits arnaqueurs et moi c'est un film
très facile à faire pour moi parce que
j'ai toujours rêvé les vrais escrocs
je suis l'onu auteur le 2
l'escroc parce que j'ai remarqué que les
auteurs enfin moins d'avoir des opinions
politiques vont assez rarement en prison
c'est plutôt une solution de facilité et
je dois dire qu'albert simoneau m'a
beaucoup aidé dans ce film parce qu'il
est foncièrement malhonnête également
j'espère qu'il est à l'écouté non pas
vis fixées à son poste qui se méfient
tout ce que je dis qu enfin ce faisant
vous m'apportez des transitions maryse
parce que vous qui prétendez pas aimé la
campagne qui vivait la campagne vous
adorez la chasse oui je chasse mais en
dehors de dourdan parce que je chasse
plutôt en sologne et je pèche aussi mis
en dehors de nous on a aussi parce qu'il
ya pas de rivière l'homme d'un seul vous
êtes un parisien tout votre métier toute
votre carrière cette année alors avec un
grand esprit de logique vous êtes venu à
premiers kilomètres de famille jacobs de
et vous êtes chasseur et pêcheur
alors il est aussi venu un peu plus loin
des enfants voulaient agir constituer
une atmosphère parisien au bistro de la
yaris que j'allais dans des bistrots
appareil a rien de changé et rien n'a
changé si ce n'est que lui ça n'est pas
changé non plus ce que vous faites vous
amuse avec beaucoup de reporter notre
métier en attendant vous qui écrivez des
dialogues et les parties présentant des
pièces de théâtre si ça me donne un nom
des pièces de théâtre mais je veux pas
faire d'adaptation des américaines je
voudrais que noriega des magies pas
d'idées pour voiler
ce travail le matin au petit déjeuner
ils ont livré durant des gouttes service
ou d'autres choses mais je n'ai aucune
idée à l'heure du café au lait qui
formate me promenais encore sous les
ombrages de jourdain ouï légal bien sûr
échasses sa voie des airs
j'ai un bon titre pour vous quant à ces
faisans